hey guys how's it going I just wanted to
do a follow-up video to my iOS 11 video
when I installed the beta and there's
been some updates since but I wanted to
go through some of my favorite features
and the number one favorite feature that
I wasn't actually able to show you guys
in the video was a screen recording so
for whatever reason when I was recording
that video my screen recording wouldn't
work the next day and restarted it a
bunch of you guys tweeted me and told me
that yours was working and you worked
for why mine wasn't well alas we are
here a few weeks later and it works so
I'm going to scroll up and I'm going to
hit the screen recording and it does its
countdown three two one and we are now
recording my screen so I'm going to go
into my camera roll and this will give
you sort of a sense of what it really
looks like as you're recording so I'm
recording right now
and this is what you're seeing and this
is what I'm seeing here's my little
monitor that I use to record and I'm
just showing you guys this in the camera
app and here you guys are right there I
would take a picture take a picture take
a picture take a selfie and that's it
that's the screen recording and this
little highlight up there shows you that
it's recording it's red scroll back up
hit stop screen recording video save to
photos my second favorite iOS alone
feature is taking screenshots and I'd
love to see a show of virtual hands
everyone who takes screenshots of
iMessage conversations and then sends
them to your friends well now this will
allow you to do something super fun so
here the conversation from my sister
Jenna I'm going to take a screenshot as
you see and it pops up right down here
so when you open it up it takes you to
this screen so it allows you to do some
things like crop maybe you said
something scandalous and you're like
well I need to crop that crop crop until
you get to what you need so I can draw
on this as well mellow pencils gonna
check you know signature
great signature came out a magnifier you
can basically do all the things that you
can now do inside of the notepad so when
you're done with your masterpiece you
have a few options you can hit this
little share button here you can message
it mail it add it to your notes iCloud
you can also choose to save it to your
files which is a nice little iCloud
storage system that is new and iOS 11
you can either save it to your photos or
delete the screenshot I'm going to save
it to my photos then I can go in here I
can set as my sister should be like what
is this it's a work of art job it's a
work of art another one my features that
I didn't mention in my previous iOS 11
video is some of the new screens you can
defend with echo unfortunately this is
mr. John of Iowa's 11 she is not going
to enjoy this beautiful masterpiece
[Music]
there's a spotlight of course all of the
other screens balloons confetti they
don't have any new level effects
hopefully they'll add some the next
thing that I've absolutely been loving
about iOS 11 is the new control center
it just feels so much better everything
is all in one place you can also
customize this to pretty much put
whatever it is that you want on your
screen I think I'm pretty much maxed out
my space except for one extra little
spot I've got the do not disturb while
driving on I've got my stopwatch which
automatically opens that up just like so
got my wallet and easy access to my
notes I've got the TV remote control
calculator camera with that
well timer okay there are just my
brightness adjust my volume and of that
I'm music here and when you press into
them it gives you some other options but
one of the things I notice is the things
music is I used to always love to be
able to tap very quickly to put shuffle
or repeat one song and that doesn't seem
to be on here any longer I see my last
favorite feature is hey Siri yes I
thought cancel si RI I don't want to say
it because in the last video all of you
guys really just saying you activated my
si RI it's so super responsive and
before I used to only use the hey si
I when my phone was plugged in where I
would use it on my watch
I've been using it for pretty much
everything now I'm telling Siri to set
my alarm I'm asking her questions I'm
telling her to turn my lights off like
everything now is integrating into hey
SI RI which is crazy because Siri isn't
a new feature but since this update is
so much faster granted she still
sometimes doesn't quite understand what
I'm asking her but that's our girl
she's not perfect but she's getting
there I love the natural voice it agrees
very well using carplay there's a little
example ready to send it read my message
again your message to Jenna and Matt
says call Jenna meet me downstairs let's
go let's go work out time you got time
Sakuya yeah yeah yeah yeah kind of
Italian about time to go left already
turn up turn up turn up I will say one
of the only things that really bugs me
about iOS 11 so far is the messages are
you guys can see here this little title
bar is at the bottom it gives you quick
access to stickers and your app store
and things like that it doesn't go away
until you scroll all the way up I do
like having that screen real estate if
you guys haven't downloaded my stickers
yet you probably should because the Madi
ones are so freakin cute well guys
that's it I just wanted to give you an
update on some of my favorite iOS and 11
features now that I've actually had a
chance to use it I'm loving it and it
still is in beta so yes there are still
some bugs but other than that no
complaints that is definitely to be
expected by something that is not ready
for release but I cannot wait I'm super
excited for the next iPhone I've seen so
many awesome leaked photos that I am
just getting more excited as the days
near closer to the iPhone 8 I will see
you guys in my next video and I hope
that you guys have a wonderful day bye
[Music]
[Applause]